maestro saputo ha vinto bene cosi a
grandissima richiesta duomi gameplay con
nuovi giochi verde personaggi su
percorsi noi estranei divertenti come
sempre lasciate un bel mi piace alla
società in questo video raggiunge i 10
mila mi piace faremo una terza o quarta
partner americano è un altro episodio in
cui giochiamo ad altri giochi mai
giocare quindi lasciate un bel mi piace
48 mettetevi comodi prenditi mi ricordi
troviamo con il primo gioco primo gioco
questo primo gioco si chiama insegnante
spaventato 3d è che c'è un bambino fuori
che saremo noi
poi c'è una signora sul metro e uno
scheletro nella fede che comunque già mi
immagino che sarà divertente questo
gioco perché in genere questi già
scritto castana fanno troppo ridere come
vi ricordate lo scorso in questi
vedevano sempre le mutande della
barriera scherzo numero uno dice di
mettere lo scheletro nel letto della
maestra tipi la vediamo ancora
ora dobbiamo entrare nella casa da
maestro persona scuola mostrano questa
casa e quello sinistro come rischia le
tre barometer nell'istanza della maestra
ma che scherzo cattivo tali sta dormendo
ok dice che ti deve nascondere e non
devi farti scoprire via ritmo non ci
dobbiamo nascondere qui vediamo come
reagisce ma sta a noi che alla fine del
video dovrete scriversi miei commenti
qual è stato il vostro gioco inedito tra
questi 3 comunque finora questo mi
piacciono descritto che dobbiamo
bruciare tutti i compiti della maestra
ma ci abbiamo proprio tipo una torcia in
mano
ricominciamo perché ci ha appreso la tv
è accorta subito dietro al muro sono
nascosta di troppo ma ok hanno generato
ma non ci andiamo di ritardo di kobe
[Musica]
o dobbiamo scappare o saliva attento
perché ti arriva terminata arrivano non
sono scappato e si sta disperando la
donna prossimo scherzo la maestra ha
paura dei rom pitrelli ma paura dei
pipistrelli quindi devi lasciare una
scatola piena di pipistrelli casa ma con
un'altra scatola casualmente suonato ai
pipistrelli dentro casa della palestra
con questa musica rilassante si fa
venire ancora piante che devi sbrigarti
ora scappa
doveva scappare ma che stiamo riparlando
ma che sta facendo la scatola e ora dove
scappa scappa scappa scappa scappa
facciamo ce la facciamo
[Musica]
ok allora c'è scritto che dobbiamo fare
uno scherzo alla maestra con lo
skateboard penso che la dobbiamo far
cadere simulare sullo skate ma avrebbe
diavolo
sul tavolo davvero non l'ho vista
brigati piccolo preso caro domini ly
trial parete ce la facciamo bella si
stima mente lo stiamo già mettendo
conviene farsi qua a scivolare aveva
sentieri e poi all'improvviso alberto
dobbiamo usare la bis e che dobbiamo
prendere il secchio d'acqua dalla cucina
comunque finora il più estremo era
quello col lanciafiamme specchio si
prendiamolo dove solo per mangiare qui
[Musica]
ok
vediamo come luci e sposò che modo diamo
questo gioco e gli do un otto e mezzo
primi fanno un tacco che voglio dare un
8 perché effettivamente faceva tanto
ridere vorrei che volta dati a questo
gioco scrivetecelo nei commenti
passiamo al prossimo giugno fratello
cattivo 3d oggi siamo tutti in cose
cattive 3d praticamente dobbiamo fare
gli spiriti al nostro fratello maggiore
cattivo ricordate che abbiamo giocato ai
fratelli cattivi sings se non lo avete
visto andate a vederlo dopo questo
perché la super divertente però in
questo caso è solo un perfetto non
maggiore blogger è iniziamo con il primo
che allora si è scritto che tuo fratello
si chiama rom non vuole mai giocare con
te quindi devi dargli una lezione
perché non vorrei giocare allora i
luoghi cushion sarebbe il cussino delle
ricorrenze non so dove si chiama in
italiano questo qua questa ci sono i
commenti così in inglese ma non italiani
d'italia brocchi abbiamo così lo
corregge so che lo vediamo qua delicati
perché è molto cattivo il fratello
vediamo come reagisce
ti amo
[Musica]
esistiamo noi che stiamo uno scherzo
dobbiamo rubare la pista e questo mi
piace
si possono mangiare io sono sempre
d'accordo la cosa che succede spesso con
fratelli ma non subire le maggiori vero
si vede se nei commenti se avete
fratello e sorella maggiore di anche
quegli rubate le cose ecco questa
sarebbe una pizza alla vito bianchi
abbiamo passate alla corsa dei teli
spettiamo sta per scoprire che gli aveva
rubato una fiat è bloccato di sulle
scale ma che succede si è pagato per
l'ultimo scalino è un po c'è un problema
ragazzi non è mai successa questa cosa
prima ma non riusciamo a muoverci e non
ti muovere anche il fratello che nessuna
stranissimo quindi dobbiamo ricominciare
da crolli ok che proprio non ha
aumentato la dobbiamo nuovamente la
cartellina bianca intera proviamo
scappare vogliamo bloccarci ok dobbiamo
nasconderci qualche sostanza vediamo su
reagisce
[Musica]
ben reggere così effettivamente dice di
prendere un granchio dal giardino e
metterlo nella bandino famosi kroenke
del giardino fino a un grazie anche voi
nel frattempo controllate le camere di
sicurezza perché abbiamo le mie mani
d'oro e purezza come cary teacher
sì lui è al piano di sopra anche noi
dobbiamo andare al piano di sopra che in
quella stanza da questa lavandino dire
che sta arrivando qui non si capisce
dove di comunque appena di fa ora
dobbiamo sbrigarci ok o mettere la
bandina 6
lui sta arrivando quasi
ha chiuso la porta ma attento bossi è
bloccato ma pur sempre vediamo prossima
scherzo allora dice di prendere il
giocattolo fantasma e metterlo nella
stanza di toro sta dormendo vedete dalle
camere
ok sara piu facile perche riguarda ma
che fai casino che carino dice che
l'inter ha subito dal letto mentre dorme
che cattivi al piano così a quello
dobbiamo mettere io però troppo
divertente guarda vediamo cambiato
prendi il gioco serpente quindi per il
serpente giocattolo e mettilo nella
stanza reso fratello il fianco
ultimamente gli volevo prendere alla
fine non è cattivo il fratello 9 sono
ora quello minore che siamo cattivi gli
ultimi quindi facciamo tutti mentis che
quindi ha ragione ad essere arrabbiato
per noi allora
al piano di sopra via libera uno come un
serpente
wow attenzione non se n'è accorto tato
mai e così vai metti serpente attivano
messo a capo una donna so non capisco
che l'abbiamo passato vediamo sua regis
e si arrabbierà anche questa volta
[Musica]
il presupposto per la prima volta che ti
spaventa mera veste questo sono troppo
bello grafico a cherso prendi la buccia
di banana dal giardino d'acqua in realtà
una banana in testa
vediamo non se n'è accorto
[Musica]
presi uno scherzo al tuo fratello piace
molto giocare ai videogiochi quindi roma
in il joystick del ma questo tipo è il
20 voli joystick del nintendo 64 vecchia
via vai a giocare adesso però questa
volta aveva ragione ad arrabbiarsi come
noi rapporto è uno scherzo altro
fratello mi piace molto la può quindi
devi farlo esplodere con dei petardi
forse forse non ci ha preso parte a
sorpresa devo parlare visto che ha
scritto giusto quanto si è scoperto
[Musica]
proprio ok così fa ora apprendiamo i
petardi che sono in uno di questi casi
ma anche lo torna membro umani di ma
siamo riusciti
io gli do un 9 ha festeggiato perché mi
piace un sacco di sky
anche secondo me se lo meritano davvero
davvero bello come prossimo scherzo si
chiama scritti c'era perché ci sono tipo
altri 100 200 che si chiamano stesso
schieriti perché maschere ognuno copia
dall'altro non ti capisce comunque oltre
a chiamarsi scheri teacher però non è
scheri teacher perché la mano e diversa
se anche mi scritti 0 si può scegliere
se essere mic o 63 tani però solo nick
però non c'è tani iniziamo viviamo quali
scherzi dovremo fare acquista maestro
maestro saputo che questa maestra e
cattivi stimato che sono siamo
[Musica]
e come ha fatto un incubo dovrà finire
miss bella ma sotto l'incubo tu capisca
sono tutti un po strani che abbiamo
identificato una cosa ti ho fondato a
scuola è già tardi
[Musica]
sono di nuovo in ritardo per la scuola
la maestra mi unirò realmente credono
nell incubo sbrighiamoci ok ok dice che
dobbiamo prendere lo zaino della sua
cameretta ha subito proprio di fronte le
nostre case che fortuna non possono
sapere aiuto aiuto a non hanno anton ego
e la cattiva ecco la nostra classe aiuto
cosa si farà
siamo stanchi micron classic possa
trovare migliorare
[Musica]
perché se il ritardo ti pulirò aiuto
dopo le parti ma questa non è una
punizione
[Musica]
ora vai a sederti vendetta vendetta
presenti preparati vista bella che sta
interessando adesso dobbiamo far
scivolare la maestra cattiva vediamo e
ci dà un suggerimento dice che nella
caffetteria c'è una bottiglia di olio
ok abbiamo anche qua la camera di
sicurezza così possiamo vedere dove ci
dice di andare a pieno nella bottiglia
giulio no scappa scappa scappa scappa
come ho fatto a trovarci e rincorrendo e
mi chiamo scappando dal corridoio non
vedo l'ora di vederla scivolare visto
che così cattiva ok abbiamo questo
l'olio pare ci dobbiamo nascondere a lo
guardiamo da qui vediamo è il momento
della vendetta
vediamo
io comunque l'ho fatto con gli ho detto
ti troverò informerò la tua vita
rossi non mi trovo che paura che fa oggi
e giorgio in cui ero coprirò chi ha
messo l'olio nel corridoio ieri miss
bella sta arrivando in classe trova
subito la trappola per il topo
[Musica]
abbastanza cosa ci vedranno tutti gli
altri così non siamo sospetti che
vediamo oggi scoprirò che ha messo
l'odio nel corridoio ciò che entra di
noel e zoe mode risiamo primari 27
[Musica]
prossimo certo dice che ora mazara la
sua zuppa preferita durante la pausa
quella è la zuppa
sembravate unito non trova la stessa
ficcarli scoprivo che mi siamo tornati a
casa a prendere la salita di catania
dove mettiamo la salsa piccante
ora si è scesi a
[Musica]
[Applauso]
e troppo secca che a volte siamo che su
ciò che gli do un 8 e un otto e mezzo
perché era super divertente sono più
cattivi del sole se vuoi che voto gli
date e scriveteci nei commenti qual è
stato il vostro gioco preferito tra
questi 3 e quale volete che continuiamo
fra questi 38 ovviamente lo stato mi
piace qua e se non mi seguite i sintomi
non mancherà andare a seguirmi il dovere
di trafori e ora cliccate su una di
queste quattro salire su quella che
preferite
buona visione ciao